Stephen Strange
the illuminati will see you now we will see
what kind of doctor strange you are
Welcome back everyone this will be my doctor strange two
video all about the big marvel secret wars arc
they're setting up a bunch of teasers during the
movie about incursions there's going to be so much
crazy stuff happening in the next couple of years
so if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos i'm doing a
giveaway for disney plus memberships all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave all
your predictions for time runs out in secret wars
in the comments careful for spoilers for the movie
if you haven't seen it yet because we have to talk
about the post-credits scene everything that they
set up and everything the illuminati talks about
with the incursions but during the movie one of
the major running story lines in the background is
that a bunch of different characters recently in
the marvel movies the disney plus series have done
things to the multiverse that have destabilized
the cosmic barrier between universes causing
incursions to start happening your arrival here
confuses and destabilizes reality the larger the
footprint you leave behind the greater the risk
of an incursion interesting to do something like
secret wars or the way they define incursions in
the mcu is that it's when one universe collides
with a cosmic barrier through an adjacent universe
destroying both of them and because the multiverse
exists in a sort of spherical like state like
a three-dimensional state the more incursions
happen the quicker they start happening in an
exponential rate so it's not a linear thing it
might have started with only a couple universes
but now by the events of this movie more and
more universes all over the multiverse are just
winking out of existence colliding with each other
so even though only a couple characters during
the movie briefly mentioned this fact like this
is really dangerous thing that's happening it's
actually a really really serious problem and it's
sort of like their next big infinity saga level
arc like this is a secret wars arc that we're in
instead of trying to assemble the infinity stones
into the infinity gauntlet now the whole idea is
that they're trying to prevent the collapse of
all reality everything in all of existence all
dimensions all universes everything how do you
go bigger than the infinity gauntlet avengers end
game well instead of trying to destroy an entire
universe you try to destroy an entire multiverse
during the movie john krasinski's reed richards of
the 838 universe illuminati team is the first to
really start talking to mcu doctor strange about
the incursions themselves and even though the
whole illuminati team kind of wants to get rid of
rmcu doctor strange if that wasn't clear they'd
seen their version of doctor strange start to be
corrupted by the darkhold and sensed him going
evil becoming this huge threat to the multiverse
so they think that all doctor stranges are capable
of this and will eventually do this so that's why
when they see our doctor strange show up in their
universe they're like oh it's happening again we
gotta get rid of them so john krasinski's reid
richards in the background is also thinking
about this big domino effect this larger
multiverse problem that's why the illuminati
in the comics were formed to solve these giant
cosmic level problems but the whole idea here
with the rate of the incursions in universes
being destroyed speeding up quicker and quicker
over time is that time is running out for the
multiverse which is why in the comics this whole
arc is literally called time runs out mild shock
there'll be a couple changes obviously for
the mcu version of this but you've started
to see this play out in the background of this
movie in the comics the illuminati of the 616
universe which they actually canonize now is the
main mcu universe if you were confused about that
now canonically because they mentioned it in a
movie the main mcu is 616 but in the comics their
version of the illuminati are alerted by their
reed richards of the fantastic four about what's
happening he's found this giant multiverse problem
universes are being destroyed we need to stop it
somehow they use their universe's version of the
infinity stones to blow up an alternate universe
earth from colliding with their main marvel
earth to prevent another incursion that would
have destroyed their universe in the movie they
actually specifically mentioned their team formed
to solve really gray area kinds of problems they
come off with this really shady vibe that's the
way they portray them in the comics like you're
not really evil but you're not necessarily that
good either you're doing really bad things they
basically blow up an entire alternate universe
trillions upon trillions of people to save their
own universe it'd be like if someone blew up the
entire mcu just to save their alternate universe
which is kind of what's happening right now with
the kang multiverse war during the movie not
just the illuminati characters talk about the
incursions the way that john krasinski's reed
richards talks about them though they do make
it sound like they're kind of blaming our doctor
strange because of what he's done messing with the
multiverse in the last couple of marvel movies
but the incursions themselves started happening
in a big way right after the events of the loki
series so some of you have asked about this and
you're all correct it's all because of what loki
and sylvie did kevin feige confirmed this recently
he said that was when the really wtf things
happened to the mcu where loki and sylvia wrecked
the multiverse so like thanos the hulk iron man
all snapping versions of the infinity gauntlet at
different times releasing crazy levels of cosmic
energy in the mcu those did destabilize the cosmic
barrier between universes a little bit but the
actual full-blown incursions like universes
colliding with each other destroying each other
didn't really start happening until sylvie killed
he who remains king during the loki finale freeing
all the kang variants and starting another version
of the kang multiverse war so even though it
gets a little confusing when you start talking
about the difference between alternate timelines
alternate universes alternate dimensions the way
that marvel is using the term they're all kind of
connected they're using the term multiverse very
broadly to define everything that exists every
big concept dimensions timelines and universes
so when we're talking about time runs out
incursions secret wars in the mcu you could talk
about alternate dimensions alternate universes
alternate timelines as being kind of like the
same thing even though technically they're meant
to be a little bit different the way they define
alternate timelines in the mcu is that you have a
universe and somebody does something really crazy
causes the nexus point once that nexus point goes
past the red line that variant basically winds up
creating an entire alternate universe and the
multiverse grows just a little bit more so at
the end of the loki series you see the multiverse
sort of spring forth all these alternate timelines
and even though we only see this for a couple of
seconds the effect continues like it continually
grows until the kang multiverse war starts
happening in different timelines different
universes start to go to war with each other and
the total number of universes start to decrease
slowly but then at an exponential rate so really
the incursions themselves started happening when
the kang variants started messing with the
multiverse but then after that a couple other
things started happening that made things way way
worse for instance spider-man and doctor strange
messing up the spell in spider-man no way home
that destabilized the barrier between alternate
universes even more causing even more incursions
to start happening then during doctor strange 2
you have scarlet witch you have america chavez
doctor strange crashing all over the multiverse
alternate dimensions messing with alternate
versions of the characters that makes things even
worse more and more incursions start happening
so they just kind of compound the effect of the
kang multiverse war but they themselves didn't
start what was happening with the incursions
that was really loki and sylvie technically in
kang variants so the illuminati john krasinski's
reed richards aren't wrong to be mad at our
doctor strange for what he's done because
he has made the problem even worse it's just that
he's only the tip of the iceberg at the end of the
movie charlize thrawn's clia comes from the dark
dimension she's dormammu's niece she's like the
daughter of dormammu's twin sister they're like
a race of beings that are kind of like asgardians
in that universe super advanced some of them gain
crazy levels of power like dormammu for instance
he's sort of like a sinister strange version of
their race of beings who just gains crazy levels
of power so originally dormammu looked kind
of like clea more humanoid clia's father was
the ruler of the dark dimension until dormammu
performed a coup got rid of him and took over
she's also meant to be kind of like the sorcerer
supreme of that entire universe so she's just
as powerful as mcu doctor strange in the comics
she's kind of like his true love interest they get
married so she is doctor strange's wife basically
mcu going full waifu in marvel phase 5. she shows
up in the mcu using her own magical portals
between universes to get our doctor strange's
help saying that he just caused another incursion
recently because of the events of the movie and
because she takes him back to the dark dimension
i'm assuming that means that the incursion
specifically is threatening the dark dimension
itself so it's like doctor strange is technically
going to save dormammu's life also the fact that
she was specifically able to target him and know
that he was responsible and he would be powerful
enough to help her amongst all the other infinite
number of doctor strangers in the multiverse
shows you how powerful she is like she'd follow
the breadcrumb trail back to mcu doctor strange
she was able to find him specifically really what
they're trying to do though is find a way to save
the multiverse stop the incursions because the
more they happen the faster they grow the quicker
the entire multiverse winds up blowing up in r.i.p
all of reality the way they play the post-credits
scene though it seems like the events of clee and
doctor strange fighting whatever incursion happens
in the dark dimension will be covered in a future
crossover movie or they might wait till big time
runs out avengers crossover movie or they could do
it in doctor strange three but what they are
teasing with all this talk of incursions is
a time runs out movie first and then after
that would be the full blown secret wars
and just to be clear we're talking about the
2015 more recent version of secret wars there
are two big versions that everybody remembers
the one from the 80s they did this whole big
toy licensing thing i include the clip in some
of my videos sometimes because it's kind of
tomorrow's super funny are coming secret wars
that was the one that they covered during the
spider-man animated series back in the 90s where
the beyonder brings a bunch of them to a planet
to do battle with each other just to test them
that was where spider-man got the venom symbiote
back in the comics obviously in the mcu things
are going to be a little bit different because
we just saw them leave the venom symbiote in
the mcu during spider-man no way home but for
instance they're kind of teasing a very avengers
infinity war avengers end game kind of scenario
where you take a big story and you break it across
a couple big avengers level movies now it might
not be the avengers movies they might just call
it a secret war saga but like the time runs out
movie would be like avengers 5 then avengers 6
would be like the full blown secret wars film
there are a lot of big characters that are
involved in this time runs out storyline and
secret wars like god emperor doom they haven't
introduced a version of dr doom in the mcu yet
but during the comic book version of time runs out
doctor strange winds up going off on his own to
try and find a way to stop the incursions kind
of like we see happen during the movie he goes
off on his own with clia he winds up finding out
that a version of dr doom has basically amassed
all this multiverse power and started capturing
this really powerful character called molecule
man which he senses will be the key to defeating
their true enemy which is the beyonders one of
the big differences of the comic book is that the
reason the incursion started happening is because
the beyonders this race of beings that existed
outside the normal multiverse basically decided
that it was time to get rid of the multiverse so
they started destroying all these universes doctor
strange winds up working with doctor doom they
cause all this collateral damage and it winds up
leaving only a few universes left but they use
that power to then try and stop the beyonders
dr doom basically steals their power and becomes
god emperor doom gaining so much power that he
basically takes the fragments of all the remaining
universes that are left and combines them into a
single universe and that becomes their version
of battle world where all the different variants
of the characters do battle with each other for
supremacy in that scenario it actually winds up
being reed richards who solves the problem like
how do we restore the multiverse he uses franklin
richard's power to create entire alternate
universes like franklin richards is so powerful he
can just conjure up entire alternate universes and
that's how they bring the entire multiverse back
john krasinski's reed richards even mentions
that his version of franklin richards exists in
their universe but for instance one of the really
big changes that they've already made in the mcu
is that it sounds like the king multiverse war
and just kang as a character will be a much bigger
figure in this mcu version of secret wars and time
runs out they might tease a little bit of that in
thor love and thunder but i'm not expecting
a bunch of it maybe a little bit in black
panther 2 later this year but really it's going
to be an ant-man 3 next year where they'll tease
legit secret wars because they have a version
of kang the conqueror who will be in the middle
of that second kang multiverse war right now based
on the timeline they'd be able to do their first
time runs out big crossover movie by 2024 so
if they pace things out like infinity war and
avengers end game and release the next couple
of big secret wars movies pretty close together
we might see full-blown secret wars around 2025
or 2026. there's like a thousand other things
that go into this version of time runs out and
secret war so if you have any questions about
what's going on with the characters or any of
the big teasers for secret wars during the movie
just write them in the comments below and i'll
cover them in my bonus videos i've got a bunch
of videos planned for the movie so i'll try to
post those in the next couple of days but everyone
click here for my new doctor strange 2 iron man
deleted scene video to learn what was going on
with him during the movie and click here for my
full doctor strange 2 post credit scene video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!